[موسيقى]
بحاول ايه منتصف الليل ليله البارحه انقضت
في اوكرانيا الهدنه التي اعلنتها روسيا من
جانب واحد ولكنها هدنه لم تحل دون استمرار
القتال على محاور عده
بوقفه نار وقال انه اكتفى طيله هذه الهدنه
بالرد على القصف الاوكراني
لا يصحبها انسحاب الروسيه قالت لنا سلاح
الجويه خلال الساعات الماضيه 24 ضربه على
مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
ومنظوماتها الصاروخيه وانها اسقط ثلاث
مسيرات الروسيه واستهدفت خمس مناطق لتمركز
الافراد والعتاد الروسي ومستودعين للذخيره
وتقول الروايه الاخرانيه اذا القوات
الروسيه شلت يوم امس ورغم الهدنه ثلاث
غارات جويه 49 هجوما صاروخيا كما سهدفت
بشكل اساسي البنيه التحتيه المدنيه وفضلت
تدافع عن المواقعها في مقاطعه اذا براجيا
وخيرسون متكبره خسائر في جبهات اخرى